when america is faced with a tragedy
americans expect a leader to step up to
the plate and bring the country together
not fuel the flames and make things
worse
joe biden ran on being that guy
in 2017 in the midst of charlottesville
biden emerged to tell americans that
there was no better guy in washington to
unite the country
he promised he would fight for what he
called the soul of america
and he'd fight for every american
regardless of party or race but what
we're seeing coming out of this white
house is the very last thing joe biden
promised he'd do
today he made it clear
it was never about you it was always
just politics for him
in his first visit to buffalo new york a
city mourning after a racist nut job
went on a shooting spree
joe biden treated it like it was just
another campaign stop
where instead of uniting a broken city
he used it to blame america for being
complicit in white supremacy
white supremacy is a poison
it's a poison
running through it really is
running through our body politic and
it's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes
no more
i mean no more
we need to say as clearly and forced as
we can
that the ideology of white supremacy has
no place in america fairly for us to not
say that failure in saying that
is going to be complicity silence is
complicity
so if you don't talk about white
supremacy all day like democrat
politicians you're complicit in white
supremacy got it
and you're the reason america is failing
the american experiment
in democracy
is in a
danger like it hasn't been in my
lifetime
it's endangered this hour
hate and fear of being given too much
oxygen
by those who pretend to love america
but who don't understand gutfeld made a
great point on the five today which he
almost never does so i'm happy to relay
it to you
joe biden is admitting that democracy is
at its greatest danger point in 80 years
while joe biden is president and while
democrats control the senate and the
congress
and after he got elected on a promise to
unite the country
is biden just reading words on a
teleprompter or is he confessing that
his presidency is a failure we have no
idea
but does this sound like someone who
cares about actually healing the soul of
america
if joe biden really cared he'd go out
there and talk about what really fueled
this rampage and why it wasn't stopped
he'd talk about the failure of school
closings that isolated this kid and
allowed him to slip into the dark
crevices of the internet where he was
radicalized
he talked about the failure of his own
red flag laws
this kid was investigated by his school
for being a wannabe school shooter he
was sent to a psych ward and was
investigated by police
but he went on a mass shooting anyway
biden doesn't talk about the real issues
to him
it's about how he's going to spin
another tragedy into a political cause
ahead of the midterms
as president united states i travel the
world
all the time
and other nations ask me heads of state
and other countries to my ask me
what's going on
what in god's name happened on january 6
what happened in buffalo what happened
to ask
that's obviously a lie joe biden hasn't
left the country since march
and i'm sure poland's not worried about
january 6th
seem a little more upset with russia
but did you hear what joe biden was
trying to say he's trying to link the
buffalo shooting with january 6th
he's trying to say trump supporters are
marching to the same tune as the buffalo
shooter
if you're ultra magga or if you're a
mass shooter you're basically on the
same side
he sees his poles in the gutter the
media's turned on him his own party's
turned on him and he's facing a bloody
midterm
so biden's feeling desperate and he's
using this tragedy to go back on offense
and chip away at your second amendment
look i'm not naive
i know tragedy will come again
it cannot be forever overcome
it cannot be fully understood either
but there are certain things we can do
we can keep assault weapons off our
streets
we've done it before
i didn't when he passed the crime bill
last time and violence went down
shootings went down
cities cracking down on guns are
actually seeing a rise in crime joe must
know that you can crack down on all the
guns you want but if you don't crack
down on the criminals who use the guns
crime will stay high
but he wants to make guns into a problem
so he can blame republicans for violence
when we all know the real violence day
after day night after night is happening
in the inner city
this is also about connecting people who
are mentally unfit to carry a gun to
responsible gun owners
then biden focused in on the shooter's
ideology his manifesto about the white
birth rate
and all of you reject the lie
i call on all americans to reject the
lie and i condemn those
who spread the lie for power
political gain
and for profit we've now seen too many
times the deadly and destructive
violence this ideology unleashes
this is what joe biden said about this
very thing in 2015 when he was vice
president watch
an unrelenting stream of
immigration non-stop
non-stop
folks like me who were
caucasian of european descent
for the first time in 2017 will be an
absolute minority in the united states
of america
absolute minority
fewer than 50 of the people in america
from then and on
will be
white european stock that's not a bad
thing that's that's a source of our
strength
not only our muslim communities but
african communities asian communities
hispanic communities and
and the wave still continues
it's not going to stop
nor should we want it to stop
as a matter of fact
it's one of the things i think we can be
most proud of
and the media obviously doesn't want to
cover record gas prices crime inflation
the only thing the media loves to cover
is trump
and reverend al sharpton one of the
deepest thinking democrats on msnbc
managed to blame the buffalo shooting on
trump
what donald trump as president did this
young man 18 was 15 years old then and
as he later says he started reading and
was radicalized it was not that radical
to him when the president of the united
states said there are fine people on
both sides the mainstreaming of this
hatred the mainstreaming of we will not
be displaced uh uh this kind of
mainstream of this opens and broadens
the the whole pathway to people like
this young man to feel that they're
standing up for something
biden's teed the media up to play the
race card and just like i said last
night the left is going to use this
tragedy to make republicans feel guilty
make sure almost guilt them guilt the
republicans well it's not their no that
is the party that's what you're voting
for you don't get to pick and choose you
don't get to say well i like their
fiscal responsibility no you see the 10
people that got killed in buffalo you
own that okay that's the way you got to
talk to people you own that so that's
the playbook if you're white or
republican you're just as guilty as the
buffalo shooter and the only way to
absolve your guilt
is to vote democrat
is this how biden pictured the soul of
america a country more divided than ever
a media
talking down half the country more hate
crimes more black on black crime
people struggling to buy baby formula
joe biden hasn't healed the country at
all
he's made things worse
and according to nbc 75 of the country
thinks we're heading in the wrong
direction
well guess who's leading us there
his speech in buffalo just proved to us
he doesn't care about the soul of
america it's just a line that one of his
staffers put in the prompter just like
ultra mega and whatever else the white
house is trying to spend but americans
aren't going to fall for it we know when
we're being divided and conquered
so how about this how about we worry
about our own souls
and joe biden can worry about how he can
stay president and kamala can worry
about how to become president
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else